welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this episode is featuring tammy peterson
my mom mom and i went into detail about
her background
how mom and my dad jordan peterson met
their life together for the last 30
years
dad's fame and touring her near-deadly
cancer
and how she's doing now if you enjoy
this episode please remember to
subscribe
this was her introductory episode she'll
be back to talk more about her future
endeavors and how she's managed to heal
and what she's learned
but i thought getting to know her would
be nice for you guys
this episode is brought to you by hover
a domain name vendor
something that makes hover special is it
has a ton of options for different
endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from
when building your brand online no
matter what you want to build
there's a dome name waiting for it you
can end your website in dot blog or dot
diet or
whatever instead of a dot com if you so
choose i use hover for that reason
adding a dot something to your website
can be a better idea than a full on new
dot com
or as my dream a few episodes ago was
you can buy a dot news website hell
you don't even have to have a legit news
company or blog or diet for that matter
just buy the dot diet domain and people
will take you seriously
i'm kidding don't lie you'll find
excellent technical support
available to answer any questions that
you may have their support team
also doesn't upsell you free who is
privacy protection a clean user
experience
and monthly sales on popular top-level
domains check them out at hover.com
mp and get 10 discount with that
referral link
below and on all new purchases
make a name for yourself with hover
that's h-o-v-e-r dot com slash mp
also linked below also a reminder to eat
salt
eat redmond salt they're the best
they're not refined so it has trace
minerals honestly my salt taste should
be taken seriously it's one of my main
foods
realsalt.com codemp for 15 off
and the link is also below aren't they
cute
they have little containers too remember
to hit subscribe if you like this
and i release episodes sunday and
wednesday i also have a clips channel
and michaela peterson clips
also link below enjoy this episode
[Music]
tammy peterson welcome to my podcast hi
michaela
good to be here i'm so excited for this
one i wanted you to come on before but
now is the time apparently now is the
time that's right exactly
i usually start off by asking people
about who they are and to give a brief
background about
yourself which might be a bit of a
complicated question for you
but i'm going to do exactly the same
thing anyway
so could you give my audience a brief
background about who you are
and what it is that you do
i grew up in a rural very rural place
in western canada um
i really like the outdoors so i spent
most of my time outdoors
and when i wasn't outdoors i was inside
drawing and coloring and sewing and
playing the piano
and playing with my bird because i had a
budgie bird and i love my budgie brain
my budgie bird could
if i played jacks there was a game where
you had these little
metal they're like little stars kind of
and a ball
and you'd throw the jacks and
bounce the ball through the jacks and
you'd have to grab the jacks before the
ball
bounced so you could catch it and my
bird was after those jacks like rad and
he would squawk at them and
then grab them in his beak and throw
them around he was a lot of fun
so we played you know when i would rest
he'd rest he he would sleep on my
shoulder
while i was sleeping we were best
friends
and uh jordan's cat one day
i was looking at the bird and the bird
was sitting on
the top railing of the front curtains of
the front
plate glass window and i called him
and he didn't look at me and i thought
what's the bird looking at and i opened
the drapes and there's jordan's
tuxedo cat on the outside a monster
tuxedo cat grape
stretched up as far as he could go he
was going to eat my bird
you know so how long how long
when did you meet dad i was eight years
old
he moved on to the street when i was
when he was seven
i guess because he's a year younger than
me he lived right across the street in
an orange house
his dad was a teacher at the elementary
school
and george was this very skinny little
kid
he was a skinny little uh sandy haired
he had straight sandy hair
and he had straight hair when he was
little he had straight hair it didn't
curl till he was
in puberty same with my son right same
with julian julian has curly hair
julian's hair well it's a bit curly but
he never had any curl until he
went through puberty same thing yeah
yeah i met george when he was eight
seven eight when i was eight
and we did things that kids do we played
we played games on the street we played
baseball in this
in the empty lots that were behind our
house we lived right on the edge of town
and he was in the same grade as me
so we hung out with some of the kids at
school too and i was very good friends
with him
you know until grade seven when
i matured and he didn't because boys
don't mature as fast as girls he was
also
younger right and he was a year younger
so i i uh
i left him to his group of friends and i
went on with my group of friends
and we didn't really hang out again
until high school
until late in high school and
i was actually going out with another
fellow but i wanted jordan to be my grad
escort because he was my best friend
and so my my boyfriend had to go away
around graduation so i asked george to
be my escort and he said yes
so that was our first date and that was
pretty cool
he didn't spend any time with me though
he spent time with his friends
at graduation at graduation yeah yeah he
was still
well he was young he was a young guy he
was probably nervous
he was probably nervous too yeah he was
probably nervous okay so what happened
in university where'd you go
uh first of all i went to edmonton and
that was
you know a good six hours away from home
so
it was away from home yeah where is
fairview because fairview is where you
guys met where yeah
it's far away it's in northern alberta
so it's
you know six hour drive north of
edmonton
uh near an hour from the bc border
so it's nearly into british columbia uh
it's it's in it's on the prairie so it's
uh
you can see we could see uh 40 miles
from the hill in our town our town was
called fairview and if you drove up on
the hill
west of town and looked you could see
communities lights from communities at
night
that were 45 or 50 miles away you just
see a string of lights like a
like a string of of pearls it was
a beautiful place and you know the you
could see so far that the
stars would come down and then you would
see the lights of the towns so you could
see the sky
and the and the ground meet
in this little cascade of light it was
it was a beautiful place it's nothing
like toronto
no but you know when we moved to boston
uh when george was at harvard and when
julian was born in boston you were two
when we moved there
um we went to the ocean every weekend
and that kind of reminded me of the
prairie because i could see so far
and so that really in a way although it
was the ocean it reminded me of home
and there's wind at the ocean and
there's lots of wind
in the prairies so in some ways the
ocean and the prairies have a lot in
common at least
uh the the uh immense sky
that you can get on the prairies is
similar to when you go to the beach
yeah i remember the ocean in boston yeah
it was wonderful it was wonderful yeah
george used to george used to build out
of sand he would drag his foot around
and make a house
with rooms and you and julian i would
play house playing those
those games i can remember that it would
have been like four or five
that was a really good game drag your
foot and draw a house and then you can
play in like the bedroom or the kitchen
of this
sand house that was a good idea yeah
yeah
okay so you went to where did you go to
university i went to university of
of alberta for a year but i didn't want
to live in edmonton
um oh no let's see when i first yeah i
went to edmonton
i just took one course i took a
psychology course and i worked full-time
because i didn't quite know what i
wanted to study i i was very creative
and it was difficult for me to decide on
one
career you're open as really open and so
it was very difficult to
hone in on exactly what i wanted to do
because everything looked interesting
but driving a bus looked interesting you
know as well as you know
uh being a painter so yeah all these
things looked interesting
so i took one course in ed and i worked
full time and then i decided
uh actually i met someone who was going
to mcgill and we drove out to montreal
and i went to mcgill for a year and i
studied arts so i studied
you know a general arts with french and
philosophy and english and
i really had a good time there it was
really fun to be in montreal although
that was about 1980 and the separatist
movement was
very uh hot then and when we arrived in
town
um we arrived in town we'd driven across
the country i got food poisoning on the
way and nearly died
[Laughter]
it's a fun trip well you when you're
when you're living out of a
a picnic box you know sometimes well we
didn't have a
we didn't have a lot of ice or anything
to keep things cold so you remember
those things i got salmonella i
remember this i got salmonella
two years ago in january you okay and i
had scarlet and she was still in her
crib
like young enough that when she wakes up
in the morning i have to go in there and
pick her up
and i was so sick i couldn't move and i
had to get you to come over
oh i remember to get scarlet up because
i had like a
fever and i couldn't yeah i thought it
was sick yeah it was like
three days of i thought i was gonna die
and then
the fourth or fifth day i could eat
again was like huh wow
that was nasty but that sounds like what
you got i wonder if it was salmonella
except for i was sitting in the bush
that's so much worse sitting in the bush
anyway it wasn't i think i was like
although to
come back to that i think i had had my
ankle replaced re-replaced then
so i think i was still hopping
i think around was still hopping around
so i wasn't in the bush but i did have a
surgery
angle okay well i think anyway toddler i
think you win
i don't know man the bush doesn't sound
good either anyway uh
after the food poisoning we went we got
to montreal and i recognized sherbrooke
street and i said oh let's get off here
so
we go down sherbert street and i'm like
this little town girl right
i'm a rural girl i lived in edmonton for
a year but i'm a
and we down sherbrooke street and i see
this guy
walking down the street and he's got on
leather shorts
and a leather vest and that's about all
you know and and boots on and
i was just complete my eyes were just i
was just glued to this guy
i couldn't believe what i saw and i
thought wow i've
you know i finally moved somewhere where
something's happening
and then we stopped at a light the light
was red and the car in front of us
turned right right into the parked car
beside him
and i was like what kind of place is
this you could go to a bar and you could
you could uh carry your drinks around
you could stand up in a bar
in alberta you could you can't stand up
in a bar because if you stand up in a
bar with a drink you're going to fight
so you get kicked out really yes so when
i came to ontario
of course i was only five foot two so it
didn't do me any good to stand up
but you could stand up and walk around
and talk yeah in montreal whatever you
wanted
until three in the morning people
socialize like crazy in those bars
yes they wanted on the streets on the
streets yeah yeah well in alberta no
that was a like
no you're gonna fight no go that's right
so it was quite a
so then i got to montreal and i just
loved it and i loved mcgill too
it was uh wonderful it was a wonderful
year it was strange to be in a place
where i couldn't get a job because i did
my french wasn't good enough and if you
spoke english
it was it was tense the atmosphere was
tense
so when i finished that year i moved to
ottawa and i finished my degree in
ottawa and
i went to university of ottawa it was a
bilingual university so i took half
my courses in french and
i got a science degree a kinesiology
degree
and i studied with a massage therapist
for a while because i wanted to do
massage
afterwards and i didn't go to the
massage school but i took
weekend courses and read a lot and
started
offering massage therapy to people and
at that time
there was there weren't that many
massage therapists around because it was
about 19
it was 1987. and uh
i thought people were new i got people
coming out of hospitals who were
dying coming to me for a massage for
some relief
it was really quite a time to be
offering those services
i had one woman she she did pass away
she had lupus and passed away oh
i had another woman she was in a cancer
treatment she came to see me she
you know she was okay but hurting and
i had i had a lot and i taught yoga i
taught yoga out of my house too
when i first went to university i'd
studied yoga since i was 13 years old my
aunt introduced me to yoga one summer
when we were tearing down the pig barn
and doing yoga lessons in the morning
it was quite a summer i took i took the
yoga
and went home and i just did yoga every
day
that is so cool i thought i don't know
it seemed like something to do
and i thought i might need this someday
yeah well
right that's for sure so i always had
that in my mind that i would need
to know how to take care of myself when
i was older
that life would get i didn't know life
would get complicated
but i i didn't know that but i
sensed that there would be a time where
life would be
too much for me and i would have to have
skills
to cope right and yeah well that
certainly happened thank goodness i did
those things because i think those
things
have well they took me through high
school successfully and otherwise i
don't think
i don't know how successful i would have
been
you know i'd come home at night after
drinking and do a
yoga pose or two and realize i'd drank
too much you know i mean it would bring
me back to myself all the time
about just where i was so it's it's like
you know when you balance when you when
you weigh something
you get it to stop at zero zero first
and then you weigh it
that's what i was like when i do my yoga
it would bring me back to myself and i
could
reflect okay i'm not i'm doing okay
today or
i'm really not balanced today or i
i could and and i did that all through
high school so that i didn't ever
really go too far one way or another it
kind of
centered me and i'm really grateful for
that because
high school can be a disaster for some
people
high school is really hard high school
is really hard i mean
people uh high schools are even the
teachers have
seem to be confused i mean it's not just
the kids are
confused and i don't know you know i
grew up in a very rural place
in a public school but i don't think
it's all that different anywhere you go
that kids are trying to find their way
and there isn't a lot of guidance
that they can listen to unless
it's i mean this was old sage
you know the yoga this is centuries old
it was something that had some
staying power power and it wasn't
the church and the church you know i
went to the church but
i didn't get a lot from the minister
that was there
and there wasn't and
they're just although my grandmothers
were religious my
mom didn't practice
so we went to church as little kids and
then
as teenagers not so much and then left
the church
and when i went to montreal i went to
church for a year there
to a united church and at easter i went
to a catholic church and it was all in
french
all they said was you know forgive me
monsignor
through the whole thing uh they were all
all these frenchmen were wearing pastel
suits and walk
it was really it was easter you know
they all looked like the easter eggs
at the church it was quite an experience
but i went all by myself right so
because george wasn't a churchgoer okay
okay so let's go
so you were in ottawa you finished your
degree you're doing massage therapy
you're now fairly bilingual now i'm
fairly bilingual and jordan gives me a
call
when was the last time you talked to him
i
used to see him at christmas you know
i'd come home at christmas
every year and then i didn't for a
couple of years
and then he said he was going to move to
ottawa and i thought oh that'd be nice
and then he didn't he got a job in
edmonton so he
didn't come so then i kind of thought
well
i'm just going to pick up my life and
and go forward yeah
so i i went out with a fellow and lived
with him for a couple of years
and then i was finishing my degree and i
got a phone call from jord that he was
in montreal
that he was doing his phd and he was
going to mcgill and so i went there
for thanksgiving in
2000 no in
19 1986
and he looked like he was doing all
right and he was a lot taller
well he was a lot taller a year after
high school
i met him in fairview he got out of his
car
and he got out of his car for like a
second or two longer than usual because
he wasn't
a foot dollar and uh
he still wasn't marriable at that point
though he was pretty much a wild man
at that point but once i got to mcgill
he looked like he wasn't quite as much
of a wild man
and that he was getting a life and that
he had a plan
and i thought that it was a part there
was a possibility that
maybe we could make a go of it because
he had already
asked me to marry him a couple of times
by then when
at christmas um at new year's
i think at new year's i said yes that
was the last time what
i don't remember hearing about this i
thought he wrote it to you in a letter
he did he wrote me a letter and and
asked me to marry him there and i
thought is this guy for real
yeah kind of something that's not very
romantic where's the knee
and the ring yeah it's like well we did
live 3000 miles apart
yeah and that you know back then to call
home was
uh it wasn't you didn't have a cell
phone
you didn't have a cell phone plan or
anything it it cost
money for a long long distance and we
didn't have it i didn't have any extra
money neither did he
yeah and it is kind of romantic yeah he
wrote me i think that used to be the way
it was
people would write letters i imagine
yeah
oh a lot of letter writing you know love
letters remember
you've heard of yeah yeah yeah so he
wrote me
i think he was probably going to europe
and wanted to know if i wanted to get go
with him and also get married
but i thought maybe he was joking
because it was written in kind of a
joking way
you're probably nervous yeah you could
pass it off as a joke if you said no
just in case that's right so i didn't
quite know how to take it so
i just kind of left that there and one
time he asked me and i said maybe
i wasn't ready yet i didn't want to say
no but i wasn't ready to say yes
i still had to see which way his life
was um
well when we got married i was 27. so
did he ask you the first time when
you're like 25 or something oh maybe 23.
oh okay that's pretty young that's
pretty young
yeah i didn't know that oh yeah
yeah no it started like that early like
the asking
the asking yeah the asking started kind
of early you just tortured him for like
four years yeah when he started to it
looked like he was going to start to
have some girlfriends
i married him as soon as you saw other
women moving in that's funny yeah
he was and he was just starting to feel
like confident and everything and i
married him
[Laughter]
okay so you so you you moved to montreal
then so i moved to montreal i moved to
montreal
and i worked as a massage therapist i
um i worked as an artist model
for quite a while i was always very
interested in art
and so i worked as an artist model and
then one of the guys that i
modeled for invited me to take his
courses
so then i took two or three art courses
and i applied
to art school and i got into concordia
so i was going to go to art school
but i got pregnant and i thought let's
see art school
pregnant i don't think they'll think
those two things
it just didn't seem like the right time
to go to art school and i wasn't sure
how toxic all the chemicals and stuff
would be that i would be using
so i decided it was better if i didn't
so i studied with
james simon instead for that i don't
need any more toxins no you don't
no you don't so i studied with james
simon he taught me to paint portraits
and
still life and uh then
jordan had his post doc and he got a job
at harvard and we moved to boston
so that was when i was two and then that
was when you were two and i was pregnant
when we moved to boston so julian was
born in boston can you tell the story
this is this is such a good one can you
tell the story of
was it you trying to get medical care or
something
in boston i was five months pregnant
when we moved
and when you were born you were rh
positive and i'm rh negative
so you get a shot you get a shot so that
you don't
uh abort your baby you produce
antibodies to it because you don't think
that yeah because you'll produce
a real thing it's a real thing is it yes
huh
okay so you'll have to pay attention to
that i don't know i didn't get tested
last
like i i don't remember getting tested
for that last time well she was probably
positive and so were you so there was no
problem
yeah maybe maybe i just haven't come
across but i'm negative so that's a
difference so when we got to boston
i you have to have this rh uh
test at six months
and so we were moving right before i
needed that
test to find out and then i would have
to have a shot so i wouldn't
make antibodies against my baby right
and so when we got to boston
uh i called uh the
and and you know america had they didn't
have doctors they had
health care centers that you would go to
it wasn't
you don't go to a doctor you go to a
health care center so i call the health
care center at harvard
and i say that you know my husband's a
new professor that we just
moved there and that i'm five months
pregnant and i need to see a physician
and they said
it's a six months waiting waiting time
to see
a physician there and i thought six
months and you said you were pregnant
yeah i said i was pregnant and i'm like
that like that didn't work i wonder what
i could do to
get in to see a doctor and bill clinton
was the president at that time
and that must have had something to do
with my decision because
i phoned back and i said hi
i'm tama peterson i just arrived here
from
louisiana and i need an appointment i'm
pregnant
and they said well come right in i'm
like you [ __ ]
come right in come on are you kidding me
i couldn't believe it anyway i can't i
went that is such a good story though
no there's a mother who's desperate
right that was a good idea
don't just try to sound more american
maybe i'm sounding a little too canadian
yeah
yeah still it's not like bostonians have
that accent
no no i know but i think bill clinton
because he was president
and he had that accent that it was in
vogue
at that time or something like everybody
thought that was a
anyway i got in to see a doctor right
away
so that was good well that's good so
what was
what was living in boston like just keep
going what happened
austin was good the economy was doing
very well under the
democrats at that time and uh
you know united states economy was just
booming like mad so
it was a great place to live and we
lived in an apartment
right outside the campus for the first
year when julian was just a baby
and uh you were still really little so
we didn't really need community but then
you guys were
gonna get older and you were going to
need friends and
a place to play and all of that and we
decided to buy a house
but so we bought a house in arlington
that's just north cambridge
on a little uh quiet street with a
five-acre park and um
i introduced myself around the
neighborhood and there were
a couple of other women who had little
kids and so we would
hang out once or twice a week i think we
would hang out
and one of them had another baby
and i used to miss my family quite a bit
i would live now i lived in boston my
family was in alberta
or in bc and so i thought you know
i don't know i just thought i i can't
just
be missing my family all the time so
when
my cousin had a baby and i couldn't go
home and be with her while she had her
baby
but our neighbor jill and kevin had a
and i thought oh well i'll just go over
to jill
and give her whatever i would have given
my cousin so
i gave her dinner and
i can't remember i may have given her a
little baby gift or something
and uh she responded by
letting me take care of her children
when when her littlest was a little bit
older and she wanted to go back to work
she gave her kids to me
and they were the same age as you and
julian so you guys had
it was like you had cousins because they
were there every day awesome we were
really close friends
really close friends and you just played
every day
and i didn't work but i drew some
portraits of some of the professors at
harvard so i wasn't completely just at
home
and that was good for me because i
always felt like i needed to do
something other than
be a mom so you had something else to do
when you were home yeah being a
stay-at-home mom
that is really hard it depends on it
depends on who you are because some
people have who you
are have less of a hard time right some
people have much less of a hard time and
some people have an impossible time
i had a really hard time um after
well i decided not to because i had a
really hard time it's like i'm just
gonna
wilt need some stimulation
bouncing off of walls here yeah
yeah but that wasn't it but it was nice
for me when i was little
i remember hanging out with kids all the
time and i know
when i was five we moved to toronto well
i turned six in toronto
so that like area when we had those
close friends that we saw all the time
didn't transfer over as well because
they were our neighbors it was really
useful
yeah that's right that was really good
and the little school that you went to
was just up the street as well yeah the
primary school
so it was really it was a it was this
really cool little
uh neighborhood it was a 50s
neighborhood
it was it feels like so yeah they had a
family five and dime store
on the mouse ave just down the street it
was a real 50 it hadn't changed since
the 50s
so it was i remember going to diners and
eating ice cream that had like cow
print on the wall yeah yeah that's right
yeah that is a cool area i kind of just
thought that's what like
things were like at those times but it
was styled
arlington in an old way hadn't
it hadn't changed but the neighborhood
we moved into
had some you know retired people
and then it had people with little kids
moving in
and jordan and i we took about six
months to buy a house we would drive
around
to different neighborhoods during the
day and we'd open the door
of the car and listen and if all you
heard were dogs barking we'd shut the
door and leave
because we didn't want to live in a
community where everybody left and
worked
and there was nobody there during the
day because i was coming from canada
i had no green card i was going to be at
home and so
he was really helpful george he was very
careful with the fact that i was going
to be at home
to find a community for me and and for
you guys
and we did and then when you were this
you were guys were very careful too when
we moved
to when we moved to toronto oh yeah
when we moved to toronto because we had
we stayed
in faculty housing for a couple of years
and then we had to find a house and we
went on to a street one day that was
having a street party
and we thought this would be a good
street to live in and then
friends of ours who had been living with
us
in the in the faculty housing had looked
at that house
and thought it was way too um old and
decrepit
for them to buy but he they knew that
jordan and i fixed it
crazy enough to fix it up and we did
we fixed it up so just to give an idea
of what that house i
vividly remember walking to that house
we were living in faculty housing so
like apartments
yeah with other faculty members um and
fairly small
apartments but we were little anyway
julie and i were sharing a bedroom
and then they go we're gonna so we go
look at this house and dad goes
you know this is where we're gonna live
because i think we must have we must
have gone to see it after you'd
bought it no i remember seeing it
slightly before that so we went in to
see it
we get in like the electricity isn't
working the floorboards are on an angle
like this
it hasn't been touched since 1930s the
basement looks like a horror show
it just has danger written at the bottom
of the stairs in spray paint it's all
clay
there's a little shack in the back it's
completely covered in bees in the
backyard it was just and carpenter ants
oh god and carpenter ants and i was in
grade so i was just about to go to grade
four
and or in grade three or maybe in grade
two because you renovated
but i remember going in stepping inside
to this
horror house that didn't have
electricity right
and there was wallpaper just hanging off
of the wall
and i remember grab yeah this is where
we're gonna live and it was like
uh i remember grabbing the wallpaper and
just like just because it was falling
off and just like tearing it off the
wall and being like
oh this is where we're gonna live okay
but then you guys
renovated for a very very long time well
i
i worked as the um contractor
and renovated it for six months it only
took six months
to rebuild the entire house and dig down
the basement
yeah it was fast basement yeah it was a
good base and then it was a lovely house
but walking into it was
like it had to be completely torn apart
on the inside
it was such a horror house that the
people who lived next door had rented
their house and wouldn't live in it
until we fixed it up and then they came
back and lived in it
wow because it was just it gave
everybody bad
it looked like people had died in there
well what happened was a family had
bought it in
like the early uh like 1910 or something
yeah
and then they were the only owners
and it hadn't been changed at all since
yeah so crazy it had gas lights on the
second floor
no electricity gas lights and
the kitchen sink was broken it was a big
old 30s
kitchen sink but there was no car there
was no there were no cupboards or
anything in the kitchen
yeah it was uh and the basement was
you couldn't stand up in the basement it
was but you could take a shovel and you
could bang through the cement there was
an inch of cement
on the floor that's all that was there
and there was a corral for
animals down there wow that was it they
must have chickens or something down
there or something
in the house yeah in the house in the
basement yeah it was winter it was
you know cold in the winter there were
dead raccoons in the walls
in the in the chimney yeah
it was uh and i said i don't think i
want to buy this house
and george said well then you can look
for those and i thought and i guess i
could have
and should have maybe but i didn't it
was a great neighborhood
it was a great neighborhood and we could
walk to work
yeah and it would have been the cheapest
house in the best neighborhood it was
good
yeah wow it was 241
000 what do you think the comparables
were in that area
like how much do you think the
comparable houses were in that area
oh they must have been double that yeah
it was really decrepid yeah it was
it was an estate sale the old guy they
had one child and he lived there
until he had dementia and then
the neighborhood people put him in an
old folks home
and sold the house oh man
he's never married or anything it had
probably broken down
yes he got sick yeah he never did
anything to fix it
ah i had i know i had so many
because it was really even once it got
fixed it was creaky like some of the
floors the old floors stayed and
it was just creaky no one would move and
it would creak and
groan and i remember at night listening
to these creeks and groans and being
like
this is haunted this is haunted i live
in a haunted house
but it was the it turned into a nice
house and your house is really nice now
no it's really nice no that i've
renovated it again yeah
it's really nice but we thought of
moving away from the neighborhood
and then we looked around at different
neighborhoods and then we'd come home
and we'd think oh but it's
there's lots of trees here and the park
is right there and
we know all the neighbors and well let's
just stay so we stayed
okay we liked it yeah okay so that
brings us
like that was that was a while ago but
you stayed in that house
um then what
where do you want to go from here well i
spent
i went to ocad i went to
ontario college of art wasn't ocad yet
it was
an art college when we first moved to
toronto you guys were in like senior
kindergarten in grade one
and i went off to art school and so i
went to art school for a couple of years
uh but then life just got complicated
and i quit going to school
i got sick you got sick but that wasn't
all
i lost a baby too and uh i don't know
that just took the wind out of me took
the wind out of me at that point
and uh so i didn't go to
ocad anymore i went back and got my
massage license
and worked as a massage therapist when
you were in junior high
when you were doing really yeah very
well yeah cause i
i got really sick and then i was put on
a bunch of medications and i got
i went into remission yeah basically for
junior high and i remember you going to
massage school studying all the time
yeah i love tents for a couple years
yeah it's quite a
it's a two-year course and it is a much
bit more difficult
curriculum then university was a science
degree
it you know it was uh you were taking
in-depth physiology and anatomy and you
had to know it
really and had to know everything
neurology
you had to know it all yeah you studied
a ton
so that was it so you got your massage
therapy the
the actual certificate yeah then i went
to work
um four other people and eventually i
just started working for myself
and so then i had people come to the
house and we had this dog
we had sico sico the american eskimo
vampire dog
he was a wonderful dog he was so mean he
was kind of two other people
yeah he was not he was a loyal he was a
he was a
watchdog yeah well people have been
stealing our stuff off the porch right
they stole
your scooter this is a good story tell
that story so we go down to bloor street
we always go down to bloor street for
to eat something on friday nights and so
i'm with my little kids
and you're not that old you're maybe i
was in grade five
maybe great i think or something like
that and i bought the kids scooters
and we didn't have very much money no we
didn't have very much money
these scooters were really special there
are those little like you know how
everyone had
razor people had razor written on their
scooters ours just said scooter
but like these were our scooters they
were they were wobbly and broken in a
certain way that made them
really really fast and somebody stole
them off our porch
yeah so we go down to bloor street and
michaela's scooter the um
the um handle got stuck and it wouldn't
go higher right
and there's this man and he's gone
scootering along on this little
orange scooter that the handles are too
low
and i stop him and i go huh where'd you
get the scooter and the kids go
mom and they go and they hide behind we
literally
yeah she stopped this six foot honestly
probably six foot four
giant guy clearly not stable on my
scooter that has scooter
you know worn off on the bottom right
the the handle bars are stuck like it's
clearly my scooter
and mom is like huh yeah where did you
get the scooter so julian and i
go into like a little crevice door and
just like
pier we're like this is this is not good
so i say huh where'd you get the scooter
and he goes
oh you know i got it downtown somewhere
and i said huh looks
exactly like my daughter's scooter that
was stolen off our porch she goes
oh no no no my uh my kid's grandma
bought it for him i said oh yeah i see
how it goes
and i walked away and then and then we
walk by a restaurant and you go
there's the kids that go to our school
there's his kids
and they're sitting in the restaurant
with her grandma and i think oh
this is just so sad yeah it's so
sad they're just kids that went to our
school their dad yeah so when you open
your eyes and you stick your nose out
and you see something like that
ah you see real life and it's
tragic often tragic
yeah yeah so then we got a dog who would
bark when anyone came
or even passed by or looked at us
sideways or came up to give us a present
it didn't matter that's right or came
over to get a massage
yeah and the dogs would bark at my
massage clients
bark away no he's okay he won't bite i
don't think
yeah yeah that's your life which was
iffy yeah super relaxed anyway it didn't
matter he we had him for
13 years and we just loved him just
loved him yeah
so much i walked with him all the time
he was really
helpful for me he was when i was sick
too yeah yes he just lay with me in bed
i know he was so nice yes for sick for
chronically ill
people having some sort of pet is can
just especially because it could be so
like lonely
when you're sick yes that having a pet
is just
they won't leave you they won't leave
you so
if that that's definitely a way to help
somebody if they're chronically ill get
them a pet
if they have someone else to help take
care of it and stuff yeah
and i like taking care of him i like
going for a walk i found walking very
therapeutic so i've always walked
um it it really
well sico he was good i liked him a lot
he would have been better if we'd fixed
his diet if we had just fed him meat
would have been better if we wouldn't
have fed him that kibble that they'd
tell you to feed dogs which is a real
disaster have a good time with that no
it's a disaster to do that yeah
but uh that was good so he died in 2016
or before that no it was just after i
met andre yeah it was
2016. we had to put him down in
january or february it's coming up to
his
the time yeah you're gonna get a new dog
i've tried i don't know i just don't
feel ready yet
uh there's just too much going on too
much going
on you know i don't know and you know
julian has rudy and rudy comes over and
i give rudy a
robin so i get i i get a little bit of
dog
from rudy so that might be good enough
for now and then i have grandkids
true and uh you know uh
scarlet came over the other day and i
have all this glass
so that so that you can see through the
house i don't want i
took out all the walls so you could see
right through and uh
andre came up and he said you're gonna
have fingerprints on this glass all the
time and i said
yeah and then i won't anymore and so it
doesn't matter if i have
fingerprints on the glass it's true oh
i know it's sentimental but it's sure
it's true though it's and then elliot
was over last night
sunday night and he was there's glass by
the basement stairs
and so elliot's on the other side and
he's about nine months old right
and he's really interested in the glass
so you knock on the glass
he can't understand and i put my socks
there and he's trying to reach through
the glass and get my socks he's just
you know he could kind of see himself
because they reflect a little bit but
then he can see you on the other side
it was quite entertaining he's a cute
little guy
he is cute he's really scooting around
man and he's actually
on his hands and knees taking us like
he's moving his knees now
oh he's almost i said to jill they're in
trouble i said just relax now because
this is yeah
this is the end of it yeah man i went to
a park
um when scarlett was she was such a good
kid
she just like sit by me she was just so
calm yeah and i went to a park and there
was a woman next to me with a kid
exactly the same age a boy exactly the
same age as scarlett
and the boy was just just taken off like
like i think he was just crawling
crawling up the hill and she'd just pick
him up put him back and just take off
again pick him up put him back he's like
crawling
all over the bench yeah and she looked
over and scarlet and i are just watching
scarlet's just sitting next to me she's
just like
boys yeah not just boys though it's just
different types different people yeah
yeah that was chill neither of you were
like that for me you didn't
you weren't terrorists neither of you
were oh well that's good
uh-uh not at all that's good so
okay so where where are we
uh we're around 2016 maybe yeah
so then what happened so then what
happened
well julian came home from university he
finished his degree
and left his girlfriend there in a kind
of a
fit of confusion and she didn't want to
come and he
needed to move on with his career and so
he ended up
coming home to do a boot camp
and at the same time there was a lot of
jordan was still teaching he was still
seeing clients
and he was getting more well he was
always suspicious
of you know ethics committees and
what was going on in the political
life and what was going on in the
university life and
how political correctness was
was coming back you know it had been
sometime when he was at harvard it was
it was starting
there and then it kind of settled down
for a few years and he thought maybe it
did settle down but then
he saw it coming back again and he was
getting quite
upset that and one morning he came down
and he said
you know and it has just been two things
happened at the same time one of his
clients had
been terrorized by some politically
correct
people and and ended up leaving her
position
at work and at the same time uh
the university was was asking that
everybody take
courses in political political
correctness and to make sure everybody
was towing the line
and these two things happened at the
same time and and he just saw
it was like a perfect storm i guess it
was a perfect storm and
he came down one morning he said you
know i'd just like to i don't know i
i i really i just want to say something
publicly
and julian and i were sitting there and
we said well you've been talking to us
about this stuff for 30 years
what could happen why didn't go go make
a public video what could happen
you've been saying this at home for a
while put it on youtube
and then that afternoon that was you who
suggested it wasn't it
to put wet on you post it up oh yeah
yeah
it was like go ahead do it make a public
video
what what harm can that happen you know
what kind of harm can that do
so that afternoon julian was on the
phone with reporters calling
to see jordan there was like people in
the living room with jordan people on
the front porch
people in their cars outside was that
professor against political correctness
yeah that one yeah that was a whirlwind
that was and we thought oh that'll last
a day
but it kept happening and it just kept
happening
and pretty it just didn't go away it
just didn't go away at all
and then the stories were in all the
newspapers
and he was he was being asked for
interviews
then podcasts and it just got
it was very busy it got very busy
and he was trying to keep up and
and trying to make sense out of what was
going on
which is kind of how his life has been
ever since trying to keep up and trying
to make sense of what's going on
yeah right yeah yeah
so that that was 2016 2017. you went on
tour with him
i went on tour with him after we had a
potlatch in our house
oh yeah right we had a potlatch on the
third floor
dad had been dad had been talking to
this guy charles who makes the most
incredible carvings for about 15 years
like they're they're very good friends
and they'd been in the works for a
number of years
along with one of dad's friends trying
to organize
something to kind of bring the native
kind of to bridge the gap between
some of the native population and kind
of the canadian government
because of the disaster that that
happened you know
up until now pretty much um and so
this started off with a potlat we went
we did part of the potlatch in
bc too yeah that was the first part
latch i think they'd had in 50 years
it wasn't because they were incredible
they were illegal for a very long time
yeah they made potlatches illegal a
government right yeah
so we went out there and we were made
part of
the were made part of the family and
then
the next thing that had to happen was
that
a number of chiefs had to come out here
and bless
the place that we were going to set up
as a longhouse
and so that's what we did and then
charles built all of these totem poles
and when we were
we renovated the third floor and put all
these totem poles up there so that's
where they are
it's where i got married and that's
where you got married yeah
this is pretty cool you can kind of feel
the power those things have up there
we turned the welcome figure around now
it used to face
towards the north now it faces towards
the south oh
it's it's nicer i like it
that's a good idea and we have a ping
pong table up there oh yeah that's
that's always a good idea
yeah so we play a lot of ping pong ah
okay so the craziness like you went on
tour with dad that was insane
well i went on tour with him partly
because
he seemed to be separating from the
family
you know all it seemed like all of this
public
uh attention was taking
was separating him from the family and
um we all noticed his
him kind of drawing back from us and not
being as present with us
and i didn't want to lose him completely
so i thought i'd better
go with him so i went on tour with him
and i worked kind of as the person who
was
made sure that every day went okay and
it did it went
brilliantly it was a perfect tour or a
manager kind of
yeah this personal tour manager because
there was a tour map there was a
there's a tour manager who went along
with us and he would go to the venues he
would get to the venues before us
and so when we arrived he was already
there and
then they would do a sound check as soon
as we arrived
and then jordan would go back to into
the dressing room
and prepare himself alone for about a
half an hour
before every show but when we first went
on tour he used to do interviews
the day of the show and then i would
notice that the shows were
that he was tired and that he wasn't as
crisp
as he would have been otherwise so i put
a
an axe over all of the interviews during
the day
and then said that between the show and
the q
a he would take about a 10 or 15 minute
break if they want to if anybody want to
interview
they could interview then oh so you want
to organize that stuck that in there
well i pushed them as far away from
the show as i could so that the shows
would be good
and i also we would go for a steak
and we figured out go to go for a dinner
really close to the theater
that way there's no stress about getting
to the theater at all the stress was all
getting there for dinner
have dinner get him to the theater and
then he was set to go
and that worked out really well we would
fly the next morning
and we'd be doing the same thing the
next day and it was just one day after
the
it was all in different cities but it
was the same thing every day
and we did that all through the states
a couple of times and then we went
through canada
and then we went to europe
and then we went to australia and
by then i think well by then i knew that
i was going to have to have surgery when
i got back
and so did jordan and
i was hoping that the tour would be a
little slower
so that i i realized when we got to we
were in europe and we went to spain
and portugal and those were the last two
places that we were going to go before
we came back to
north america and i took some time
away i hadn't taken any time away i was
really structuring my days to go along
with him
and make sure that everything went and i
just started
leaving him to well i think i had it
pretty organized by then
and so i could just kind of leave him in
the afternoon
he would have a rest oh yeah that's
right i dictated that he have a rest in
the afternoon
before his show so when he went for a
rest i could go do something and i
started going to
museums and and uh in madrid i hired a
bike
one of those bicycle couriers to take me
around the city
and so i was starting to have some fun
that was like
those were the last those are the last
that's after scandinavia
and like that was after much of the
world had been
done by then yeah but then we went to
australia
and the company that we hired to take us
put security in place which we'd never
had
and also um they were
i don't know they were there weren't
that many places we were going to go to
in australia
so we we didn't want to make it a very
short time because of all the time
change
so we spread them out and that worked
out well so that we got to maybe walk on
the beach or
go to a koala bear sanctuary or you know
so we did some nice things
and and the next time there's a tour
whenever that'll be
after this covid stuff um we'll do the
same thing
yeah we'll do the same thing yeah we do
not need to rush around
no wait i mean it was interest it was
exciting and it was interesting but it
was
exhausting it was exhausting and uh
after all that's happened i don't think
that either
jordan nor i are up to that again no
do it a different way we don't have to
do that and we don't have to do all that
press we don't have to do any press
right through anything
yeah yeah well podcaster yeah yeah
yeah seriously uh that is currently my
take on it too
and podcasts are
podcasts are the only form of con of
communication at the moment where you
can actually see the person for what
they are
even like instagram you see this picture
and it's this
even my instagram although i have
podcast clips but you see a picture of
somebody and then you
you decide what they're like from that
and twitter is not good no
it's tough too few characters you don't
understand a person from that yeah it's
like failing
yeah facebook's kind of dead in my
opinion um
but youtube long-form podcasts
or youtube channels where you if you
choose to watch the content
then you can actually see what a person
is like so we better be sticking with
that
yeah so after we so after i came back
and had surgery and
complications and all of that
then and jordan went to the hot and then
jordan went in
the hospital after i came out and was
better
once i was home again which was really
when you guys left for russia because i
had been in connecticut
all of the fall so i came home with him
in november
so we were we were in we were home for
maybe a month
yeah it was basically the tour in
australia and then everything just went
to [ __ ]
yeah until
now so i stayed at home
and recovered yeah and you had you had
you needed to recover because what you
went through
almost killed you yeah so i had a lot of
recovery to do
you look great now though thank you your
hair
your hair is recovered oh yeah my hair
fell out
yeah it was not good like you're scared
and it wasn't because of chemo or
radiation
it was stress i think i know nutrition
malnutrition
god damn it yeah it was malnutrition
because i
wasn't getting any nutrients to my body
all my nutrients were
leaking out of my body mm-hmm so we're
not going to delve into that but
no it was i'm much much better all i
have is a little bit of nerve pain in
this foot
i've had it for two years now so i think
i'm gonna start going to an
acupuncturist
to see if i can get it but it's not too
bad but
it does limit how much i can walk
comfortably
yeah try it it that's too bad it takes
like nerve pain
when after i had my ankle done i had
nerve i didn't really have nerve
pain though luckily it was i had pain i
didn't have nerve pain i had numbness
yeah more than anything i have tingling
and burning
oh that kind of pain yeah and i think it
was because i had swelling in my foot
and it disrupted the nerves i think
that's what happened
because i've had ultrasound and there's
no
nothing there that they say they can
identify as trouble
so i think that's what happened anyway
it's not that bad and i'll deal with it
but
yeah see a chinese yeah acupuncturist
you know i do i do a lot of yoga i do
pilates and stuff it doesn't bother me
when i do that it's when i walk
so let's let's um let's finish this off
by
how so like the last couple of years and
even the few years before that really
since 2016
not not that me being sick was a picnic
or anything but
really since 2016 things have been very
stressful
um and then you got really sick and dad
got really sick and you've managed to
stay incredibly i don't really like
using the word grounded
but you've managed to stay incredibly
grounded
and i would say just from the outside
you look like you're in better shape now
after what would give some people ptsd
you look like you're in better shape
than you were before
this that's i am in better shape yeah
and it's it's quite
it's quite obvious from the outside so
how
just to wrap it up because i know we're
running out of time do you have
suggestions for people because people go
through such
horrible things like how do you how do
you survive these things or try and
make them like put make them
make you stronger instead of crush you
down well you know when i was first
diagnosed with cancer
they told me it was treatable and so i
thought okay it's treatable i'll just
do this and and and move on and so
i came home from australia i had surgery
six weeks later i was walking from
you know midtown to the lake front and
back i was
i was in good shape then i went to my uh
six week doctor's appointment they told
me actually no we were wrong
what you have is a type of cancer that's
i mean we never see because everybody
dies so fast you're going to die in 11
months
if we we we have to do surgery like
right now and there's no chemo
rate we don't know how to treat this so
all we're going to do
is is take your kidney out and all your
lymph out and hope for the best
and uh i thought oh i'm gonna die
okay well i'm 57 or something i can't
remember quite how old i was
that's not too bad because i've had
quite a bit of cancer in my family so
people have died young and i thought
okay i'm going to be one of the people
who die young
i can understand that it happens
and then i came home and i went to tell
you
and julian and i thought oh
wait a minute this isn't about me
whether i decide it's not up to me to
decide
my fate this may be my
first mature thought in my life my life
isn't about me
it's about the service that i give to
the people
around me and that's what my life is
for and that's what my life's for now
like as far as i'm concerned i died and
came back to life
so and probably and spiritually i've
been reborn and i think i understand
what reborn
means now and i think this is something
that when you get sick
and it looks like there's no way back
then you have to prepare yourself for
what might happen
and um
i was put in a position where
i was at the mercy of
medicine and luck really
and so all the prayers that came through
all the people that
jordan and i had met on tour i i
breathed in those prayers
you know the night before my surgery i
breathed in gold
prayers to myself and i asked myself why
i turned against myself and
like why these little cells it was like
they had turned away
that's what it was like it was like hey
you guys
like where'd you go we have a job to do
here we
everybody else is keeping me alive you
guys what do you turn the right way for
but they were turned away for good and i
couldn't
turn them back to me again and then i
realized
you know through this meditation i was
doing
that i had to give the cancer to the
universe because
cancer is too big for one person and so
after that moment anybody who would
offer me any
prayer or any relief of any kind or
or just a smile or anything i would i
would take it
i would take it and bring it to myself
and i was
i i realized that it wasn't that it
wasn't a it was i wasn't doing it
exactly
for me i was doing that to survive
so that i could be someone who could be
of service to jordan
right be of service to you be be a
grandmother for my grandkids
so i had these other things in my life
that were
that were important and
maybe i was going to die but i was going
to do whatever i had
in my power to do to stay alive
and really prayer
was a big part of what i did you know i
had a very good friend come to the
hospital
when i was in the hospital for five
weeks every day she came
10 in the morning and we prayed for two
hours a day
and i just cried and told her my life
story really
and prayed and i still pray every day
she taught me the rosary the cat and i'm
not catholic but she taught me
the the rosary
and i memorized it and i
i read about it and i understand it
and i pray at every day
to start my day and i meditate every day
to start my day and my attention my
intention
always is thy will be done
i'm in service for god's
will and that doesn't mean that i'm not
taking part in life i am but i'm
not the person who's making the
decisions
i'm not playing god anymore
i'm not going to be the person who says
yes or no
i'm the person that says what can i do
to help
and so then the things that i see
to be helpful i know are the things that
are good
otherwise i can't tell if i'm trying to
make something happen
and it's not happening easily then my
intention isn't with what's right
so i have to pause when i think
something has to be done i have to pause
and see it start to appear to me
i'm so bad at that it's really it's
really takes a lot of
uh a lot of
patience and trust and trust
you know when you don't have trust then
you
are playing with
so in the 12-step program the second
step
is the step that you choose to have got
in your life
and that's that's trust
to admit to admit to yourself that you
are going to give up control
and you're going to trust yourself
with a part of you that has
uh is a higher power
a part of a part of you that is
all-knowing that you're going to wait
be patient and be open
to seeing that manifest
so that you know which way to go it
takes a you know it's uh
it takes a lot of practice you can't
because you can't force anything anymore
and you and you can't tell anybody what
to do anymore all you can say is what
you experience
so i've i've really turned from someone
who was always
sharing in my massage practice i was
sharing
to someone who's doing service so i went
one step closer to being a spiritual
person
because i was sharing which is spiritual
when you're sharing with someone and
there's a
relationship there's some spirit there
but now it's
there's sharing but there's also now
there's more
service so i'm i'm offering i'm offering
but i'm
trying to offer what is right
and not force what i want
or what i think is something that
is is uh going to be useful i have to
i have to see it manifest before i can
um take action
and that's a hard thing to learn i've
had a hard time learning that it's taken
me
a whole year but you know the people i'm
working with say
takes people like 20 years to see you
have
doing that in a year is really really
fast
and so uh with people who are sick
this is a this is a lifetime of learning
but every little step you can take
to give yourself up to
the um
the power that is there in your heart
the more peace you'll find in your life
is it does it have to do with and then
we really have to stop because i know
you have to go
yeah we can have you back on okay do
more that would be fun yeah i'd like to
talk more about that stuff
okay um do you think a lot of that's one
last question then then we really have
to stop
um do you think that's intuition is that
what you mean
intuition like your kind of gut instinct
about what you feel is right and
sometimes you fight that is that what
you mean by
what you were saying about your heart
yeah well people you know they might
you might talk to me and i might be
thinking about what you're saying and
trying to say well is she coming from
the right place or did she
thinking about it yeah yeah you know
you're not thinking about it it's not
you're not thinking you're talking more
from your heart and i would say
intuition uh yeah right
into it people would say intuition
because they was not using your brain
to logic out whatever you think is going
on no just go with that feeling
well and it's to notice what's around
you because you'll see
miracles you'll see things happen
so you'll you know let's see maybe i can
just give you a quick example
um so just the other day anyway i had a
i got up in the morning and i was saying
that i will be done
i was going through my day saying that i
will be done knowing that god's going to
tell me something this day
and i don't know what it's going to be
because thy will be done thy will be
done
it's it's from uh the lord's prayer
and is that just thy will
god's will yeah be done yeah okay okay
yeah yeah not my will yeah right
god's will so thy will it's just a very
quick
uh prayer that i can say to keep me
present
because god is in the breath god's in
god is in between the words god isn't
the word so when you're talking
and you take a breath that's where god
is
that's that pause between your words and
that's where your intuition is too i
guess right that
it's that it's that pause you take with
your children when your
your children are doing something
frustrating and you pause and then you
then you watch and then you see
an opportunity to be helpful
and then through that helpful you find
what you were into
what you were curious about because then
you're full of compassion when you're
helping
and so any question that you'll have
won't be coming out of judgment it'll be
coming out of compassion
and so it's your intention that has to
be with compassion rather
than judgment so so if you're there for
judgment then it's you
taking control and pushing god out
if you pause and wait for an opportunity
to be helpful
then god is there yeah
it's very cool that does sound cool
it is it's very cool i'm not quite there
yet i'm there
you can go that's good i can see that
you're there i can see that that you're
there
well mom thank you so much for coming on
my pleasure
i think people are going to like it that
was a lot of fun so nice to see you
[Music]
you